hello some Dave Robinson from data cab
I'm gonna be talking about why you
should teach the tidy verse to beginners
this is a topic I've talked a lot about
before on my blog variance explained you
see a couple posts starting in 2014
recommending the people teach beginners
ggplot2 rather than built in are
applauding in 2016 I shared more about
why I use ggplot2 and then spread my
belief that I'm really it applies to all
the tidy vs. the play are ggplot2 tidy
are and the rest of the ecosystem and I
bet you're wondering whether this talk
applies to you and so it's worth
clarifying what do I mean by teaching so
who here will consider themselves a
teacher of our it's a great crowd and I
think I'm a lot of us would imagine
we're thinking of lecturing students so
there's some certainly have some college
professors or high school teachers or
people that um teach are here to
beginners but I'm also referring to a
lot of other ways you can make a choice
of what to teach so for example you
might be evangelizing to coworkers so I
do a lot of this is when I was working
at Stack Overflow or at data camp trying
to figure out how can we on board new
people into our and it might be in
public speaking or advocacy like here
Lisa Simpson telling everyone they
should use ggplot2 may be the kind of
thing where we are doing a blog post and
analysis do we want to get people into
data science you understand how do we
get them in so teaching is not just for
professional teachers so I'll share how
I recommend teaching are and then I'll
go into the why so if I if the fire
alarm went off right now and I would had
to leave I'd be happy as long as I got
this one slide in have goals for what
you want your students to do and start
them doing it as early as possible and
that sounds like it's some kind of
general but has some very specific
implications
one is that order matters you can't just
say well I plan to teach all these
things in the course so I'll teach this
early I'll teach this later
you should put a lot of thought into
what the someone's first and
pression of our is and it also means
that when you teach something you should
show why it's useful immediately not
later on so my goal when I try and get
people to use R is I want people to
understand their data and this is a
workflow of a tidy verse way of working
through what kinds of things you might
want to do with data import tidy
transform visualized model and then
communicate the results and largely the
set of tidy verse tools are very
well-suited for each of these steps so
my way of teaching R is kind of
encapsulated in my data camp course
introduction to the tidy verse so you go
to data camp and tried taking this
course it has its intended for people
that have never used R or even program
before and it has 4 chapters first
teaching data wrangling how could you
take data and do what you need to tidy
it and bring it into an analysis it has
data visualization with ggplot2 it moves
on to grouping and summarizing so steps
you might do after you've tied your data
but then you can go back to
visualization and and show it in other
kinds of ways so a su I said that these
are things I want students to do let's
give them a few tools that allow them to
do it I have a follow-up more Advanced
Course called exploratory data analysis
in our case study and that's meant for
people that already have some experience
with R and with deep IR but I think a
very similar approach of I teach people
to clean an ant and transform a data set
to visualize it to model it using my
broom package which works very well with
the apply on ggplot2 and then to join
and tidy that data with with other data
sets so all these courses this is
generally how I really like thinking I
think about the kinds of package the
kinds of parts of an analysis that
students would want to do and I match
the the packages to those problems so
why is the tidy bear so well suited well
could say that it's powerful people in a
couple lines of code can get a lot of
output this is a graph of my first
course so it's something that we can we
don't just
say Oh and you'll learn in my week 1
learning week to learning week 3 on the
last day you'll understand something
from your data here for example students
were able to understand the relationship
in country demographics in just a couple
of lines of code in the first hour of
using our and it's also consistent so
the gid verse was largely set up so all
the pieces work together and it works
according to a consistent philosophy so
we will don't have to deal with lots of
arm of memorizing little fiddly details
this is one example that I was kind of
really am excited to see the FS package
is a is a 1 package within the tidy
verse that works with file system
operations and there already are tools
in fat in the file system that I'm in
are for working with the file system but
they use different naming conventions
because they were added at different
times by different people
lowercase Path thought expand or camel
case normalized path or capitalized sis
chmod or file dot access and these are
really difficult for students because
every time they learn something they
have to shift their method of thinking
and it's very hard to memorize them so
the tidy verse has been really well set
up for beginners to get on board onto it
because it uses consistent syntax so
anytime we choose what to teach first we
have to choose what to leave until later
and here there's some things that people
might consider really important parts of
our that we don't get too early in a
course so one example is data structures
neither these courses talks about what a
factor is how to how to create a matrix
or even what a list is almost everything
is done on data frames and it's under
Tomic vectors
it doesn't introduce loops so there's
things that will say I'm for loop and
none of the courses work with that
because they can often be replaced by a
group by in a summarize we don't teach
conditionals these are considering and
they they properly are a fundamental
unit of programming but it's not
included within how we might deal with
data and the tidy verse and we don't
even necessarily introduce users to our
for defining their own functions
there are some context where it's some
useful but it's none of these courses
would discuss something like that so
these are the kinds of code you might
recognize from maybe your introductory
our course or your trajectory
programming course some like basic
examples of how can we do an if and how
can we create a function that adds three
to a number so we probably take these
kinds of code examples for granted but
take a look at them they're all useless
they're not doing anything this is
looping through and it's printing
numbers from 3 through 13 though 3
through 12 this is a function to add 3
to a number why would I need that as
opposed to adding 3 here's an additional
that is printing something when we
introduce these units of programming we
have to avoid these kinds of examples
that aren't alongside an actual useful
example so I think where is a good place
that we can show these include these in
a curriculum I think are for data
science by have they will come in
Garrett column and is a really good
example of an ordering of how things can
be taught and are so here there's about
30 chapters of an introduction to our is
all available online really terrific
book a notice that introducing that
writing someone's own functions is
introduced in chapter 19 and iteration
with loops and I believe conditionals as
well is introduced in chapter 21 so
everyone knows students do need to learn
these but they didn't have to be the
first things notice they started with
the with data visualization data
wrangling how you tidy data so why do
people teach these kinds of approaches
first why do people feel like we should
teach if and for loops so who's seen the
movie Karate Kid
so in Karate Kid there I think a lot of
people kind of model themselves off this
teacher mr. Miyagi from Karate Kid if
you haven't seen the movie this is where
he is having a student Daniel he's
having him um
wax his car and paint his house and do
these other meaningless chores and then
Dan finally gets really angry about it
and it's
only later that he realizes that the
whole time he's been learning karate
without even knowing it so I think a lot
of people think think of a teaching are
that they'll do something similar
they'll teach a for-loop that doesn't
actually do anything useful but then
later when the student needs it they'll
realize that they've been learning
powerful methods all along so I don't
like this approach I think that mr.
Miyagi really was kind of doing Daniel a
disservice because as I said my
philosophy would be start people doing
your goals as early as possible so when
someone a beginner walks into a class
what might they be want I want to learn
so typically someone might be in the
crowd and say um well I want to draw
conclusions about my gene expression
data set or maybe they have a psychology
experiment they need to interpret the
results maybe they have an internship
coming up they'd like to analyze data
for their job so these are the kinds of
goals that students gonna walk in and
they're they're ready to put in the work
to learn these things what aren't they
thinking they're probably not thinking
well I really want to hear what a loop
is I've heard so much about them they're
probably not thinking I need to know the
six types of atomic vectors no one's
going insane if I don't if they don't
talk about function scoping I'm gonna
lose my mind so you're teaching these
things really early on you're losing
students attention and if you structure
your course like this where you say more
progress as more progress happens you
can um start off going slow but later it
all comes together into something that
students can do you're kind of starting
with people saying well why would I need
this and later on telling them oh I get
it now it sounds like it works consider
what if they quit right here I mentioned
that of the kinds of teaching um you
might do working with co-workers or
public Abbess advocacy in a blog post a
lot of them have non captive audiences
nothing stopping them from quitting we
they're busy people they've got jobs to
do and they're not necessarily going to
stay to wait until it all comes together
a better path might be that the further
progress you make in the course the more
can do in a linear trend so people are
always gaining more and more power in
fact you can probably if you're a little
bit clever structure a course so it's a
bit front-loaded where you can kind of
follow the 80/20 rule solve 80% of
students problems as early as you can
and then start getting to the details of
other things they might need to do later
in the course
so if sometimes heard the criticism that
perhaps Heidi versus training wheels
it's very good for beginners but how far
can people really get just using the
tidy verse tonight I'd respond that
Julius silky and I wrote a book text
mining with art and the entire thing
goes through many examples of exploring
visualizing and modeling text data and
the whole book doesn't use a single loop
or conditional we weren't trying to
avoid it it's just that you can get a
huge amount done with the tools in the
envy tidy verse so there are exceptions
to rules like this this really isn't
them isn't it absolute and I think there
are few good examples of when you
shouldn't teach the tidy verse first
won't be if you're it's really about
what your goals are so I mentioned
before my goal generally would be get
people understanding and analyzing data
but you might have a different goal one
goal your students could have is they
want to learn to program who they want
to build their own our packages and and
then you might really want to learn
things the fundamentals of programming
they can apply them to other languages
for that it's a very reasonable goal but
it asked two questions one is why are
you choosing are are isn't necessarily
the best first language to learn if
someone if you want to teach programming
fundamentals because it's usually used
for one particular domain understanding
data and because there are some things
in other languages like for loops that
can be very bad habits in are because of
the way that their language is designed
another is are you sure that students
are as interested in writing and
publishing packages as you think that
they are so this is a crowd of very
committed people that have all really
been a is really quite selective people
that care a lot about our we're here on
a
today if you raise your hand if you've
ever submitted a package to cram just
consider that even in a crowd like this
most people don't feel the need to write
their own packages or to publish them so
sometimes teachers will start and say
well I think everyone's gonna want to
build code other people can use maybe
they don't maybe they want to understand
their own data another goal could be
mathematical understanding if you want
to learn to teach things like PCA you
want to teach them I inspaces you want
to teach things about how people can um
can really model and and do a
statistical understanding of data from a
mathematical approach the tidy verse may
not be the right start the philosophy is
still true you want to teach things as
have the goals and teach them as early
as you can you probably start by
teaching matrices before teaching data
frames you'd probably teach linear
algebra before you teach the methods of
relational algebra that being group by
and joins and really kind of sequel
syntax that deeply are imitates so
really you can see it's described by a
different kind of vocabulary and here's
a case we might want to teach the
abstract before the concrete because the
abstract is what you actually want the
students to understand if you are
picking a case study it might really be
secondary and might not reflect what the
um what goals are hoping to get across
and the students so think if you're
aiming to teach programming or aiming to
teach math and you're sure that's your
goal those are some valid reasons not to
teach the tidy verse first so what's
next for me this year
is in January I joined data camp and
here we have a really terrific set of
data about how people learn so I'd like
to plan some work to get evidence behind
this and get a really good understanding
of how people can actually learn are
what kinds of mistakes they make and how
we can help students through it leading
to a process we're calling data-driven
curriculum development I look forward to
talking a lot about that this year and
if you want your team to learn the tidy
verse if you want to kind of spread it
and you think this is a good philosophy
a really good way to do that is data
camp for business so we're sponsoring
and we have salmon
over there that are manning the data cap
booth and you should absolutely talk to
them my course untidy verse our
exploratory data analysis a ton of great
people's of course is like Max Q and as
of course andreas Miller has a course
there's lots of material in terms of to
get people to UM to learn and do things
in in both R and Python and it's a
really good way to lead your team so
absolutely talk to the data cab people
afterwards about how we can help your
team with learning and if you're
interested in being an instructor and
you want to teach data science to a huge
audience over two million registered
users you should go to data capcom slash
create and we apply to become an
instructor so here this anything is a
really good crowd for people that you
might have something that you're an
expert in and you might be able to
communicate and I'd be really excited to
talk to you about that afterwards thank
you
you
you